[Música]
no no
gracias que tal muy buenas muy buenas
noches y bueno hoy yo estoy aquí parado
frente a ustedes para hablar sobre mis
dibujos que hace unos 67 años subo de
forma constante a las redes sociales que
hablan por mí y que se hacen cargo de
las cosas que digo siento y pienso hoy
sucede al revés estos dibujos me mandan
al frente a mí a hacerme cargo de ellos
y a contarles un poco más y a sumar les
unas palabras
todas las mañanas me levanto a dibujar
todas así como el panadero se levanta ya
sepan yo me levanto y hago dibujos
porque me considero un trabajador del
arte una persona que fabrica dibujos
en un momento de mi vida yo estaba en
pareja y comencé a vivir ese pequeño
ritual de la mañana que consiste en el
desayuno y la charla previa a
despedirnos entre sueños y la ganja
cuando la rutina no se para para que
cada uno continúe su día yo me quedaba
en casa
dibujando tengo el privilegio de
trabajar de ahí y empecé a querer
retratar esos momentos esos instantes
llevarlo al papel y empecé a subir estas
ilustraciones que hicieran más ameno el
inicio de la jornada el mate el café el
desayuno en la cama los abrazos entre
frazadas todos estos dibujos serán
potenciados por las personas que le
comentaban a robando etiquetando a otras
personas diciéndole un buen día para
sentirse más acompañado era una especie
de postal del dibujo que se mandaban a
través de las redes sociales fue
simplemente querer captar un instante de
belleza cotidiana y llevarlo al dibujo
porque la belleza no es algo lejano
inalcanzable para todos nosotros
está muchas veces a nuestro alrededor en
nuestro cotidiano en nuestros hogares
cuando me puse a dibujar nuestros
hogares nuestras casas
querían que sea una casa genuina no que
sea la casa de la publicidad de solemnes
y limpia si vienen muchos mis dibujos
las paredes están sucias la cocina está
sucia hay una mancha húmeda la pared y
las personas que están en dibujo le
están dando uso a esas casas les está
dando vida que la vida que le damos
otros a diario me gusta mucho cuando
leonés en los comentarios en esos
dibujos que las personas le incorporan
su cotidiano a la ilustración
generalmente yo cuando dibujo intento no
sólo transmitir de la línea sino lo
decente de los sentidos me gusta que es
que se sienta el olor a comida que sale
una olla en un dibujo un plato de comida
caliente en las manos
un gusto de cerveza de un vino o el
sonido de un vinilo y lo que más me
gusta cuando subes ilustración es que
las personas les cambian muchas veces
esa comida ese aroma porque traen su
cotidiano las cosas bellas de ellos lo
que le conmueven y se los suman al
dibujo y se lo comparte en los
comentarios
continuando dentro de nuestros hogares y
ahora sí yendo a las camas
un lugar donde suceden muchas cosas
lindas como dormir en mi caso cuando me
puse a dibujar en un borde cada más tal
como indica el título quise ironizar y
reírme de las situaciones de sexo ahí
desde un lugar cotidiano natural sacando
lo burdo y lo agresivo siempre me
acuerdo que en mis primeros dibujos de
mayoría los personajes siempre están
tapados con una frazada siempre y le
ponía mucho detalle a la frazada porque
aún no me anima a dibujar los cuerpos
por tabúes propio que tenía aquí
rompiendo que lo hice con el tiempo por
regla de las redes sociales hasta que un
día hice este dibujo disculpen los
menores eso le pasó el primero amigo no
a mí
cuando hice esta ilustración
la subida instar a la gente se acabó de
risa pero la subida a feo y la perdí uno
fue censurado y la página cerrada al
otro día cuando vuelva a recuperar la
cuenta
vuelvo a subir esta nueva versión
con una frazada que los tapaba en una
especie de pseudo rebeldía que tuve
muchas personas tiene en cuenta que
estaba siendo irónico por la situación
de censura con el dibujo anterior
pero lo lindo fue que con el tiempo el
dibujo tuvo su propio significado porque
muchas personas creían que él me ahogó
era una especie de calor interno que
tenían los personajes al estar tapado de
pies a cabeza incluso fue compartido por
un montón de personas que si supieran
cuál hubiese sido el mensaje original
mi mamá lo compartió
es el único dibujo compartido
ese dibujo el que le conté que están
desnudo le dio paso a estas
ilustraciones no se rían con los chistes
pretensión mí
ese dibujo fue muy importante para mí el
que me censuraron porque dentro de
establecer un nuevo código ahora los
cuerpos son protagonistas no las
frazadas y los colchones sino en ver el
acento está puesto en ver cómo cae en
esas pausas los colores de la piel los
pliegos de la piel los pelos los pelos
la diversidad de las parejas los
tatuajes o no tatuajes
fue muy gracioso y lindo leer como las
personas que ven ser ustedes rompían su
intimidad etiquetando a robando a otra
persona y siendo amor anoche hicimos
esto
mañana lo vamos a hacer o este maldito
nico nos están espiando
hay que decir que también se llenaron de
muchos comentarios negativos en contra
de la diversidad en las parejas y eso
recuerdo que en una charla que di este
año en la ciudad de la plata- hablando
justamente de los cuerpos y humor de
cama un muchacho que estaba en el
público se levanta se levanta no perdón
levanta su mano
y me dice adelante de todos las personas
que estamos en silla de ruedas también
hacemos el amor algo que yo nunca había
ilustrado todo este momento y que él me
invitó a ilustrarlo dos días después
subí este dibujo que se viralizó y se
compartió un montón pero fue esta
persona que le dio visibilidad
primeramente no yo
ahora digo que son un montón son miraba
don omar
saliendo continuando dentro del
cotidiano pero saliendo de nuestros
hogares y en nuestras camas nos vamos a
los paisajes todo lo que a mí me
transmite la naturaleza como se dan con
el conecta con todo a través del dibujo
y todo lo que me trasmite la naturaleza
lo intente depositar en la ilustración
en este caso el esfuerzo está puesto en
transmitir a través de los colores de
las luces de la sombra de los contrastes
mi intención en este dibujo es que las
personas se inviten a recorrer esos
paisajes que generalmente siempre están
acompañados por una mochila la mochila
es un símbolo que tenemos todos que es
un símbolo que significa viaje encuentro
que la podemos cargar un termo o una
botella con agua un libro invitarnos a
pasear por esos lugares que a veces hago
muchísimas lunas que también hay una
mochila pero paisajes agost árboles
sierras pasto el pasto es algo que está
cerca de nosotros siempre puede ser una
plaza un patio o una vereda
y transmitir desde una atmósfera quería
generar que las personas sientan la
brisa que cae sobre los hombros la
humedad que te queda en las manos o en
el culo cuando t se levante nos tiene un
rato
siguiendo dentro de lo cotidiano no
pasemos a la parte de las cuestiones
políticas y sociales que nos atraviesan
a todos que en mi caso también las
atravieso a través del dibujo a mí no me
sale discutir en la sobremesa de un
asado doy mi opinión dibujando cuando
sucede en las cuestiones de recortes en
jubilación en educación pública o la
masiva protesta de los docentes hice
esta ilustración en la que el
protagonista es el niño que reconoce el
esfuerzo de esa madre trabajadora que
sale a luchar por la educación pública
de la reconocida agradece a través de un
dibujo yo le llamo madre pero puede ser
un padre un hermano un primo quien se da
muchos los que están acá y muchas las
personas que nosotros conocemos también
sucede cuando no podemos pagar la
factura del gas cuando incendia de la
amazona o cuando los dinosaurios senado
no quieren desaparecer aparece un
conflicto que muchísimas veces son las
personas a través de su mensaje ese es
el pueblo que generalmente me avisa que
está pasando esto cabe si uno no lo ve
por la vorágine en las redes sociales
porque la media comunicación
invisibilizan o por la ceguera de uno
también
considero que cuando uno hace arte y se
compromete con el contexto político y
social está acompañando y participando
en la toma de conciencia que es dolorosa
pero necesaria para cambiar y
transformar el mundo
no es el final
cada uno podrá encontrar sus formas sus
herramientas para hacer elevar cada vez
más voces y darles peleas a estas
situaciones
hoy cuando arranque a esta charla civil
les dije que venía cada hacerme cargo de
los dibujos en realidad estoy acá
gracias a estos dibujos
y simplemente fue querer contarles que
los condimentos son los elementos con
que fueron creados este dibujo con que
forman parte históricos son nuestros son
nuestro cotidiano nuestro día a día
porque todos tenemos diferentes cuerpos
un paisaje por recorrer un perro un
gatito o una casa despelotada un
desayuno en la cama mil abrazos para dar
mil mates compartidos con amigos y
amigas que espero que me convienen
cuando baje acá
siento que la rutina siento que lo
cotidiano mejor dicho nos tiene a todos
envuelto en una mesa en una misma rutina
que si aprendemos a mirarla ya
compartirlas podemos encontrar muchos
más luces sonidos colores y aromas de
los que imaginamos gracias y gracias
dibujados
[Aplausos]
[Música]